i wanted to bring this up this this
point right here who do you think is
responsible
for the fact that this all got really
really bad the censorship and everything
first and foremost
adolf hitler i'm not going to blame the
victims i think it's
the the left the democrats the political
establishment they want the censorship
progressives cheered it on
and then they started getting censored
going oh no why am i getting banned well
because you empowered them to do this
interestingly though one of the
politicians that we have ted cruz who
has been very vocal
about censorship and calling it out said
something very interesting the blaze
reports
ted cruz you can blame the trump
administration for not reigning in big
tech censorship bingo
i could never get the people in the
administration executing the policy to
get serious
about stopping censorship here here ted
cruz wow 100
yeah it was an entire four years
in office and it moved and that we had
the power we're probably going to have
the power i don't know if i consider
myself republican anymore but
we didn't do anything and it was almost
the biggest complaint we had because
it was just getting worse and worse and
worse i remember every year leading up
to the 2020 election everyone was saying
at least on the right-wing sphere was
saying
you know that it's going to get worse
and worse and worse and worse and it
just kept
going and no one's trusting i and many
others said
trump will not win if they don't fight
back and in 2018
i said one of my favorite the favorite
one of my favorite segments is
republicans are too stupid to stop
censorship
and spineless no no no no no don't say
ignorant because they don't say ignorant
trump was not ignorant
trump knew and had everyone around him
all of his core support base screaming
at him
hey yeah please we're getting
obliterated
here his core base of supporters his
personalities that kind of brought him
into the situation
into the position where he where he got
to be president all of those core people
were taken out one by one and they were
screaming help
help help and then donald trump didn't
do nothing and now we're here today
where twitter just announced i don't
know if you've seen this
twitter announced that they banned
donald trump for life
yes even if he decides to run for
president of the united states
ian i went to the white house with bill
ottman
i'm saying bill ottman for the people
who don't you know because obviously you
know who bill is
so uh i went with bill he's the ceo of
mines ian and bill
are i'm sure there are other co-founders
but you are two of your co-founders for
mines
mines for those aren't familiar is a
social media platform you can use it's
actually got tons of
functionality it's great and we went to
the social media summit why
because the trump administration knew
this was a problem
i thought it was going to be an actual
conversation
where i'd be able to go in and see some
people in the administration or in
government and say
here's what i think the issue is now i
actually said i was asked in an
interview
what are you going there for and i said
i think conservatives
too often think they're the only ones
being censored
and there are many progressives who are
anti-establishment or anti-war who are
getting censored too
that's why it's not about just
conservatives it's about allowing people
the right to speak
before it's too late instead donald
trump put on what i would call a vip
trump rally
now mind you donald trump is hilarious
it really is it was a stand-up routine
he was it was self-deprecating humor he
was talking it was it was like it was
almost like jon stewart
level kind of comedy and i was impressed
and i'm like well we're not getting
getting
anything done today someone asks a
question they
so they're doing q a and then and then
someone said will you join
to trump directly will you join any
other
you know social media platform and trump
goes which one
which one and that was it he never did
he has no idea what he was doing he
didn't understand technology
he never talked about fusion power he
never talked about he would say we need
to ban
section 230 like he's a more he's not a
[ __ ] he was ignorant of technology
unfortunately not really i mean he used
twitter as a bully pulpit he used
twitter as
a way to speak to the people directly
away from the mainstream media so you
can't say he was totally ignorant of it
he knew the game
he played the game very well he played a
very poorly because he was banned
for himself i mean he just destroyed his
legacy but
then when it came to standing up for the
people that supported him he
he let's be honest here he didn't do
anything for him and it wasn't only just
text
it was also the second amendment he did
nothing in favor of the second amendment
when he had the house he had the senate
he could have passed legislation
that could have helped the second
amendment didn't do any of that hold on
that's the that's that's the
establishment republican party the first
two years
trump was in office it was paul ryan
the republicans who are in power are
like here's the way i describe it
when trump and bernie led there a siege
on the establishment tower
bernie eventually got bought out and
joined the ranks thinking that was the
best way in trump was just banging on
the door screaming
once he got in the establishment
republicans were like
well we normally don't have to work all
of a sudden now we got this guy yelling
at us claiming he's in charge and now we
have to do work i retire i quit i'm out
i'm not running for re-election and they
were just bowing out like crazy
and then the democrats came in and won
control of the house
so the republicans in 2016 17 and 18 or
i should say 2017 and 18
to the end of 2018 they didn't want to
do anything and they didn't do anything
so trump didn't have them in his corner
now that trump is out and it's back to
biden the establishment is back in
control
they're going to lock the doors bernie's
going to get the boot it's it's not
going to happen with the progressives
and
the left populist thought was going to
happen censorship is going to get
extreme to the point
where well they're already banning
progressives tons of progressive youtube
channels got nuked recently
and i'm sitting here going listen i'm
not going to rag on these people i'm not
going to insult them i'm not going to
mock them and say told you so i'm going
to say welcome to the fight
now can we please get a serious
conversation about why you need to be
allowed to speak
hopefully now that they're listening we
can have some kind of
i think majority that opposes where
would that conversation happen when when
people are being censored
and you can't go outside you can't go to
the bar and you can't have events yeah
you know here so depressing
you can kind of have the conversation on
youtube as long as you don't insult
people
kind of i mean we uh youtube's youtube
is pretty bad in a lot of ways but we
were talking a little bit before the
show it's not as bad as a lot of people
think it is
yeah it's better than most you know yeah
like uh youtube takes
intent into question when it comes to
hate speech seriously yeah
and twitter doesn't instagram doesn't
none of those do i think there are
people that are banned
off of everything but youtube like
people that still have their youtube but
are banned off everything else
i was thinking maybe the problem with
free speech and forcing free speech on
these social networks is you want to
allow the private networks to maintain
control of their terms of service
because it becomes kind of authoritarian
when you tell them
how to they keep changing their terms of
services i signed the term
services with the social media companies
and they keep changing it
that's not fair especially with
individuals that put their whole
livelihoods
their whole business their whole salary
on social media and then they just
change the change the rules midway
and they'll say by using the service you
would you would accept it automatically
and plus the terms will be like 45 pages
long which is like
almost impossible for a human to go
through why don't we just
i don't know maybe create something new
or treat some some of these social
networks like a utility in the sense
that
there's no banning at all if someone
goes out in the middle of the street and
screams
a death threat at somebody else yeah the
cops will arrest you for that you can't
do that you can't go around screaming
i'm gonna you know do this to you or do
that to you it's illegal so what if
there was just a platform
that was i that functioned very similar
similarly to
if you were walking around outside you
can buy ad space on it
it's the certain ad space on the site is
controlled by individuals who bought the
rights to
run ads on it or whatever and if listen
here's the way i put it a lot of these
advertisers freak out because they're
like i don't want to run ads on twitter
because people on twitter say mean words
and i'm like you put up a billboard in
like la for instance
what's going to stop some crazy racist
guy from standing in front of your
billboard screaming
and then someone taking a picture and
putting it online right you can't you
can't escape that
so maybe we need and honestly i think
it's probably
uh it's it's kind of i don't know maybe
a moot point
as of now because we we've said it so
many times we need
a social media platform that is a
utility
it doesn't have to be twitter and you
know what trump could have done it
that's the big thing
yeah trump could have got on parlor gab
or mines he could have
even made his own broadcast platform
where you go to like you know trump's
the word of trump.com and it gave you
his personal twitter feed he could have
even done done that
and then people would have followed
trump could have launched his own
network he could have done
everything and he did nothing man even
if he would have joined just
one of them whether it be gab mines one
of these other ones
it would send such a massive wave of
people to join just
because to be made aware of it you know
and it's like he never did it
it's it's messed up would you suggest
using
the government to make one then like a
socialist type of utility
i don't think that's socialist socialism
is owning the means of production
yeah publicly owned with a bill of
rights the bill of rights guarantee
so the reason i like the idea of a
public utility social platform is
because we have the first amendment
that means you can go on there and you
can say dumb opinions whether you're
left right
whatever and unless and and you ca there
is speech that is illegal
and i think for the most part there are
a lot of free speeches free speech
absolutists who will say
even inciting or threatening is just
words they don't hurt anybody
most people right now accept directing
someone
instructing them in like telling them to
do it or
actually doing it themselves like
threatening you can't do that that's
illegal
right so if like like i said if you were
walking around
you know new york city screaming i'm
gonna i'm gonna do x to you i'm gonna do
whatever you
ah the cops would come and be like right
this way buddy that's illegal that's a
that's a threat
new york they might just scuttle you
along and say get out of here because
they don't want to deal with it
in chicago take it more seriously in
chicago if you threaten someone like
yell it
they they very well may arrest you
because that's assault according to
chicago law
we could just do that you got you got a
problem with someone you don't like
their opinions block
bye-bye now i never see you again the
government could take mind's code
and start it just spin one up they could
easily do that publicize the hell out of
it
binding this so much influence you could
just publish and make it all about law
make it listen listen the big
corporations would
have all the power and say on there too
because that's that's the one of the
reasons why the government's not doing
anything sitting on their butts as
people are losing their rights to free
speech right now
and again you don't need big daddy tech
deciding what you can and cannot hear
leave it to the law we we have libel
laws right we have
laws against threatening other
individuals leave it to the law
we don't need tech oligarchs
unaccountable people
deciding yes or no you can and cannot
say this what do you mean if we
that the big techs would have control on
that if they're because again when you
look at the government right the
government has been essentially bought
and sold by the special interest by the
billionaire class by the multinational
industrial
uh industries out there that of course
do the bidding for them if you think the
us government represents you
you're fooling yourself they don't they
represent the people that they're
friends with that are super elitist that
are super rich
that cash their pockets with money those
are the people they serve so if the
government creates something
who you think is going to get the most
prominent voice and more control over
everything
it's going to be them obviously who
would we who what what organization
would we use to enforce
like free speech laws then if not the
government it's called free speech
you don't need to enforce free speech
again if you have local jurisdictions
like in chicago like in new york they
usually handle the situation
themselves so if you have a jurisdiction
and if you have someone
that slandered you or libeled you deal
it through
that system that's that's just a simple
way of doing it decentralization
not centralization is the answer thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you